efectivamente Juan la asamblea nacional
como tú lo has dicho aprobó este informe
que recomienda el juicio político y
contra el presidente de la república es
un informe que no es vinculante apenas
una recomendación pero se requerían 70
votos para aprobarlo de los cuales se
consiguieron ciento o cuatro votos por
parte de El parlamento Pero qué pasa a
partir de este momento para continuar
con el proceso que apenas una de las
fases para considerar así el juicio
político y contra el presidente de la
república Bueno A partir de ahora debe
haber una solicitud formal por parte de
una asambleísta para solicitar al órgano
calificado de la asamblea el cal el
consejo administrativo de la legislatura
para que este se presenta esta solicitud
debe requerir este asambleísta 46 y
firmas para ello donde debe presentar
inclusive Cuáles son las infracciones
cometidas por parte del presidente de la
república esta solicitud formal la hará
la fracción parlamentaria que agrupa a
la revolución ciudadana une se ha dicho
que será quienes presentarán esta
solicitud posteriormente el cal tendrá
tres días para
o no y presentar entonces una solicitud
ante la Corte constitucional quien
tendrá posteriormente seis días para
emitir su dictamen de admisibilidad
posteriormente también debe tener las
pruebas y los cargos que se le imputan
al presidente de la república a partir
de este momento entonces queda en manos
de la corte constitucional si aprueba o
en todo caso Sí archiva esta segunda
intención de cesárea funciones al
presidente de la república pero si
aprueba este dictamen la corte de
constitucional posteriormente entonces
vuelve a la asamblea nacional En este
caso pasará por la comisión de
fiscalización y quien luego deberá ser
así una informe por parte de esta esta
mesa legislativa donde va a recomendar a
través de un informe si se recomienda o
no en un juicio político contra el
presidente de la república Y a partir de
ahí continúa el proceso diez días para
presentar pruebas 10 días para
defenderse el presidente de la república
diez días inclusive para mantener el
informe y posteriormente pasa así a
realizarse la sesión en el pleno del
parlamento donde inclusive el presidente
de la república tendrá el tiempo para
defenderse dos horas para defenderse dos
horas para su interpelante Y de forma
también el pleno decidirá con 92 votos
si cesen funciones al presidente de la
república